hey I'm Michael Bay and I am a strong
believer in protecting the cinema
experience this is my edit room here in
my house in Miami I love cutting here
because it's quiet this whole system
pipes to Santa Monica where I have 5
editors yo yo bye
anyway those are my editors I can
connect with like different room it can
see what I do on my mind system here and
we can share screens a great way to work
a movie like transformers needs to be
seen using the very finest tools the
best sound technology best projection
technology and cameras I'm here to keep
three-d alive and the only way to make
it the best experience for you is to
shoot it natively that means two cameras
two eyes and see exactly what you're
seeing we're the first movie to ever
shoot IMAX 3d we placed these two
gigantic cameras on top of each other to
give you amazing resolution just like
your eyes you see depth it is beautiful
and it's something you cannot fake we're
going to spend the extra 10 to 15
million dollars and we're going to do it
right we're in fact the only movie this
summer that was shot in native three
days so an image like this to post
convert is virtually impossible see
those buildings of little particles here
they have to capture each one of those
and put them a different space whereas
when you shoot it natively it's already
doing that for you
the scale of the Transformers movie is
meant to be seen of bigs coming with
great Dolby Atmos sound and brightly lit
3d screens Michael is always on the
cutting edge of technology for the
audience to have them have a more
visceral experience is filmmaking is a
very three-dimensional style
transformers has been a giant part of
our brand it helped build imac michael
is the very first filmmaker to take two
of these cameras and configure them on a
3d rig and shoot in 3d in real time and
that's not trivial the resolution the
detail the clarity it really is
mind-boggling
there was a lot of [ __ ] shoot I keep
saying this is my last one and I'm going
out with a bang this is a big scale
movie
you